representing the government this morning
the minister for a social care is Helen
Whiteley hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program very much
appreciated
um
has nadeem's a heart we've been on
fairly treated
well the Prime Minister has followed the
process that he said he was going to do
he appointed an independent ethics
advisor to Laurie Magnus it's Laurie
reported back the Prime Minister saw
that report and on the basis of that he
made the decision that's
how we should be removed from his
government yeah but do you think he's
been fairly treated well no I don't
because I think that process was exactly
the right thing to do the Prime Minister
was under pressure to act more quickly
but he said no he was going to follow a
fair process he did that so Laurie
really set out in some detail the
reasons for uh the the Judgment the
things that he saw that Nadeem zahawi
had done wrong or had not done and that
was the basis in which the Prime
Minister made his decision I understand
that but as far back as last July of a
red flag was raised by officials over
his financial affairs cabinet office
proprietor and ethics team Etc allotted
Boris Johnson so Boris Johnson knew why
would this prime minister not known so
this is one of the things that the
independent ethics advisor set out in
his report that there are opportunities
that Nadine zahari could have been more
transparent about his Affairs so when
you're appointed a minister you get
asked a series of questions you have to
fill in a register of your interest
those are opportunities when he could
have been transparent and he wasn't that
was one of the reasons why he was sent
to not comply with the ministerial code
so which led to the prime minister's
decision to remove him from office
but by that very process there would
have been opportunities for the present
prime minister to be aware of the
financial dealings Affairs of of the
then Chancellor the then
um
what was he was the chairman and now of
course he's been sacked so there were
opportunities for the prime minister to
have known what was going on before the
ethics advisor had to look into it but
this was a problem is that is exactly
what the ethics advisor put in his
letter which was the fact that these uh
that this wasn't declared by Nadeem
zahari in that process
expected him to have declared it for the
cabinet so the Prime Minister was not
informed of these things you would and
you would have expected to leave the
Harvey to declare it in the process I
mean I've been through this myself no of
course when you get appointed you get a
phone call asking you a set of questions
which is your opportunity to say whether
there's something that that the Prime
Minister ought to know before they
appoint you and also say you fill in
your register of Interest these are the
places where ministers declare things at
the point of appointment and Nadeem
zahari didn't that was all set out in
the letter but what I'm trying to get to
the bottom of is are you telling me that
civil servants and the cabinet officers
propriety and ethics team would not have
alerted this prime minister to concerns
about the financial affairs of Nadeem
zahawi oh what I'm saying is the prime
minister didn't know about the things
then have come out and set out about it
well this is the process and that's this
is as the process which general means
that ministers have declared all all
their interests and the things that
should be known it's really important to
make sure that there should be no
conflicts of interest or actual
perceived conflicts of interesting these
are things that you know as a minister
taking on the important responsibilities
in the cabinet office are saying whoa
you need to look at this guy's finances
and that isn't passed on to this present
prime minister I'm not going to give you
a different answer from what I just said
because what I've explained unbelievable
is what the Prime Minister uh knew and
as I said was set out in the report
yesterday that was why the Prime
Minister made the decision uh that nahim
zahari had to be removed from government
okay the lib Dems feel his
transgressions are so heinous he should
have the whip removed why they're on
well as um he's he's been fired from
government you know this is very serious
consequence because he didn't comply
with the ministerial code
um but he was still elected to be a
member of Parliament and we can spend we
can talk about this one I will just say
that I've come here to talk about
something that I know that people really
care about I do the interview questions
this is what my viewers want to know
about and I'll ask the questions in the
order that I see fit if you don't mind
um why should you not have the whip
removed are you happy with him still
being a conservative I'm happy with the
decision that the Prime Minister has
made
so you're happy with him still being
conservative and still representing the
conservative party from the back benches
as I said and he was elected to be a
conservative Member of Parliament I do
think no clearly uh as set out by the
independence ethics advisor it was very
serious uh what he had or in fact hadn't
set out but I also have worked alongside
him in the department of health during
the pandemic I know what a fantastic job
he did driving the progress with the
vaccination driving the vaccination so
that we got millions of people
vaccinated in this country from covert
head of many many other countries and
that's something I'm really grateful to
him for making that happen Okay Deputy
PM is next in the firing line
um he has something like 24 civil
servants who've claimed made formal
complaints against him for bullying how
can the PM avoid this becoming another
disastrous set of headlines for him in
the papers well the PM is determined to
make sure that there is integrity
accountability and professionalism in
his government that's why when things
like this when complaints are made there
is a fair and due process followed so
that is being followed in this
circumstances with the Deputy Prime
Minister as it has been with Nadeem
zahari prime minister got the report
from Nadim tahari's behavior and made a
very rapid and decisive decision to
remove him from government meanwhile I
would say ministers like me are we
getting on with a really important job
working on people's priorities I am here
to talk about this and I will talk about
that and the thing that people really
can't have eight minutes with you and as
I said I'll decide how we uh conduct
this interview if you don't mind
um are you not concerned that the Prime
Minister could find himself in the same
position with
um the Deputy Prime Minister as he has
with his former chem I'm not going to
prejudge the outcome of uh the
investigation that's going on and I'm
sure the Prime Minister will make the
right decision when that report's back
okay talk to me then about the NHS
remote monitoring um
how is that going to work for elderly
people
um give me more detail I'll just take a
I'll just take a step back so what we're
doing today is we're announcing our plan
to recover urgent and emergency care so
this is where because we know that
people have been waiting too long in any
I've had to wait to get ambulances I
know people are really worried about
that you know if you call an ambulance
you want to know that ambulance is going
to come we want to make sure that is the
case so we've already got tons of work
going on in the NHS to improve that
during this winter but we know that also
the months ahead are going to be hard of
course you know that we've got more
people living longer that's a good thing
but with it more people who have
multiple health conditions extra
pressures on the NHS as a result so
we're putting more investment into the
NHS and specifically a billion pounds is
going into the NHS to support with this
this is 5 000 more beds 800 new
ambulances the money just to pick up on
that question was announced at the some
statement just a couple of months ago as
part of 14 billion more from the NHS but
we're also going to do things
differently so that was to your question
about caring for people at home so this
is hospital at home sometimes called
virtual Wards which are already been
piloted in some parts of the country
they're working really well already so
you need to have that there are two ways
in which this is working at the moment
one is for instance keeping people out
of hospital if they at risk of being
admitted which is often the case of
somebody who's frail and elderly but if
you give them extra support at home then
they might not well not need to be
admitted I met somebody who's really
grateful for this and leads a couple of
weeks ago looked after through the
virtual by their Community Healthcare
team another model of it that's working
really well is when someone's discharged
from hospital
and knowing that you'll be remotely
monitored at home do you have to Wi-Fi
for that to work so some of these things
do indeed rely on having a Broadband so
so having
um uh monitoring thing that checks your
blood oxygen levels yeah uh so if you
don't have a finger what happens then
well that so so what will happen when uh
doctors are considering whether somebody
can be discharged into a virtual Ward is
considering what the setup is for the
patient at home who's likely to be with
them
um and you know will they be happy for
instance to use technology actually this
is something that was started to be used
in the pandemic and because we saw lots
of people
um are you know are actually very
comfortable with using apps being online
making video calls things like that and
the patient feedback from it so far is
really good so the patient experience is
also about 5 000 more beds um how are
you going to staff those there's 133 000
vacancies so it's not just about the
beds I mean clearly a bed is actually a
kind of measure of of uh the Staffing
that goes with it so yes those beds are
staff beds that work
we are recruiting more staff into the
NHS so for instance we set out in 2019
an ambition to have 50 000 more nurses
in the NHS by 2024 and we're on track to
have those 50 000 more nurses since 2010
we've got more than 35
000 more doctors so we're recruiting
more staff to the NHS we're also
recruiting extra support stuff okay for
instance for extra emergency medical
technicians to help paramedics and
ambulances more support staff alongside
doctors and nurses just before I let you
go our Deborah Haynes has an exclusive
report suggesting our army is no longer
a top level fighting force France have
increased their their spending by 40 on
their military Germany 100 billion uh
have up their spending budget as a
result of what's happened in Ukraine
should we be spending more money on the
NHS or on defense well you make a good
point that government has to make
difficult decisions about where we spend
money we are substantially increasing
our spending on Health and Social care
14 billion more announced at the Autumn
statement we are also substantially
investing in defense and supporting
Ukraine through these really difficult
times clearly so I don't accept that
question at all I mean we have the
largest defense spending any country in
Europe and we're in progress in a 242
billion spending plan over 10 years for
defense equipment so we really are
investing in our defense but it's still
not good enough according to the
American General that we've spoken to as
I said we're investing in our defense
because clearly keeping people safe is
the first priority of government good to
talk to you thanks very much appreciate
it